if you are a known illegal alien in New
York City we've got you we know you're
in the country illegally do you know how
long it will take to process you through
the New York City office of Immigration
and Customs Enforcement when I say
process I just mean have a meeting take
a guess what would you say would you say
it will take a month seems like kind of
a long time maybe a month maybe three
months six months a year nine years nine
years the New York City Ice office is
fully booked through 2032 according to
an official document obtained by the New
York Post if you get arrested right now
from immigration enforcement in New York
there will be more than 39 200 illegal
aliens who have to be processed before
you even have to show up for a meeting